Prof: Okay,
I need two volunteers here at
the beginning,
while we're waiting for
everybody else to come in.
You have to come up here and do
something.
Come on up.
Okay.
So each of you -- actually I
don't want two people that are
sitting together.
So Lucas, you;
and Julia stay.
But Rick, why don't you come up?
So here, come here, come here.
So your job is to grind -- this
is a spice -- so you grind it up
good, and then we're going to
take it back and show it to the
people around you;
we're going to smell it.
Okay?
See if you can -- you have to
really grind it,
like this, look.
Okay?
So we've got two spices here
that we need to identify.
Okay, you can go back and grind
them at your seat and then show
it your neighbors.
Later on I'm going to ask you
whether you know what it is.
Okay, so here's how we're going
through the history of organic
chemistry and the development of
the molecular model.
So generation by generation.
And last time we got up to
students of Kekulé,
who actually did experiments to
allow people to figure out
something about structure,
not only what was connected to
what --
that's constitution;
remember, the nature and the
sequence of bonds.
So we had composition,
what elements are there,
what ratio they're in,
how many atoms.
Right?
Then constitution,
the nature and sequence in
bonds.
And now we're going to see if
you can go beyond that,
without cheating and using
X-ray diffraction,
to figure out how things are
arranged in space;
so structure.
And we talked last time about
Koerner's proof of positions in
benzene,
and his proof that all the
positions in benzene were
equivalent to one another.
And today we're going to go
really to the next generation.
Koerner wasn't all that much
younger than -- or he was at
least halfway in the generation
there.
But van't Hoff is a full
generation beyond.
So we're going to look at him.
It says under him
"tetrahedron",
and it says down here
"tetrahedral carbon".
And also we'll see something
about Albert Ladenburg and about
your, whatever,
great-great-chem
ical-grandfather,
Peter Kohler at Harvard.
Okay, so as we were closing
last time we were looking at
this definite picture of the
arrangement of atoms in space,
where the models are clearly
real models,
held together by rubber tubing,
and they're tetrahedral,
and it explains why there can
be three isomers of
disubstituted --
symmetrically disubstituted --
ethane.
Of course it was wrong.
Do you know why it was wrong,
why there are not three
different models?
Yeah.
Because you can rotate about
the middle bond freely;
it's not frozen in one rotation
here.
Or is it?
We'll see something about that
later on.
That turns out to be what's
called conformation.
Remember, that's one of the C's.
But now we're in configuration,
how things are attached to the
tetrahedron.
Okay, so after Paternó
had published that,
he got a letter from his former
sponsor,
who had moved on,
Adolf Lieben,
an Austrian who was at this
time in Italy;
first in Palermo and then,
at this time I think he was in
Northern Italy,
I think, in Pisa -- oh,
Torino;
it says up at the top,
"Torino,
25th of June,
1869."
And you can see a translation
there if you click.
But anyhow it says:
"My dear Emmanuele."
(They corresponded,
like several of these people
who were great friends;
were for a very long time.)
"Permit me to make an
observation regarding the
isomerism pointed out by you and
by Cannizzaro."
(It's a little bit misleading
to say "by
Cannizzaro."
He was very cautious about
this, as you know,
but he introduced the paper.)
"Between"
(and he shows those two
structures here.
Which look like type
structures, with those brackets.
And you can see what's fastened
on the two carbons is H^2Cl
H^2Cl, and H^2Cl,
H^2Cl.
But he wrote the Cl's
differently, obviously meaning
to denote this difference in
phase of rotation.)
"Certainly it's not
absurd, this kind of isomerism,
even without any differences
among the four valences of
carbon."
(Remember one could've been
straight, one crooked,
short, long or something like
that.)
"I believe, however,
that I don't err when I suppose
that the same cause which keeps
me from accepting it will also
keep all the other chemists from
doing so,
in a silent agreement with one
another.
You perhaps haven't thought
that accepting this kind of
isomerism crosses the Rubicon
which separates speculation
that's considered legitimate
about the mode of combination of
atoms from speculation which is
less legitimate about the
position of the atoms in
space."
(And notice here that he added
as an afterthought,
vero;
the true position of the atoms
in space, rather than just
chemical position.
Right?)
"In all speculations that
have been made up to this time,
people have always been careful
never to let enter in either the
relative positions in space
(Distances and surroundings of
the atoms).
This idea doesn't even enter
into the speculations of
Kekulé
about isomerism and the
aromatic series."
(So he draws the picture of the
hexagon and numbers 1 to 6.)
"Kekulé
believes that chlorine 1,
chlorine 2 positions is
different from chlorine 1,3 and
from 1,4,
because in the first case the
two carbon chlorines find
themselves combined with one
another,
but in the second case they're
separated by CH,
and in the third case they're
separated by two CH's.
And to accept this,
one has no need to make
hypotheses about the
surroundings of the atoms."
That's really weird isn't it?
He says in one case they're
connected to one another,
in another case there's a CH in
between, and in another case
there are two CH's in between.
But to talk about this you
don't have to talk about the
surroundings of the atoms.
That doesn't make sense to us,
right?
But it's the difference between
drawing a graph,
which is just a graph,
and drawing something that's
supposed to show something in
space.
He goes on and says,
"It could be that the two
chlorines in positions 1,
2 are in truth more distant
from one another than the ones
in positions 1,4!"
(And he draws an exclamation
point there.
Right?)
"This just doesn't enter
into Kekulé's hypothesis.
Making hypotheses about the
relative positions of the atoms
in space would make possible two
isomers of dichloromethane,
even accepting the symmetry of
the four valences…"
(That is,
that all the valences of a
single carbon are equal to one
another.)
"…and the existence
of a single isomer of methyl
chloride.
For example,"
And he draws the two structures
here, the ones where the
chlorines are far from one
another and when they're near
one another;
but that's just the graph,
that's not where they are in
space.
Okay.
He added as an afterthought
between the lines here,
"There would also result
two isomers of ethyl
chloride."
"I repeat that I don't
consider this kind of isomerism
absurd.
But since we have no means to
know the topographic position of
the atoms,
while we have many to know how
they are connected to one
another,
I consider it a bit dangerous
for science.
Shooting off into space in
search of atoms,
one risks losing the ground
under his feet."
(Right?
So be careful former student.)
"Greeting to Cannizzaro,
and Koerner,
Amato.
I'll write soon to Compisi.
Your friend, Adolf Lieben."
Okay, so be careful.
This isn't what structures are
about, right?
They're just graphs that show
constitution.
So here's Koerner,
you remember,
before he went south,
in Ghent, with Kekulé.
And on the right of this group
is Albert Ladenburg who,
once you know,
once you've read what he wrote,
you can sort of read into his
attitude there,
that he was a hard guy to deal
with.
Okay?
He thought he knew a lot,
and he did know a lot,
but not as much as he thought.
So he published this paper the
next year, in 1869;
or the same year that
Paternó
published his thing.
"Kekulé
adopts two hypotheses:
(1) The 6 hydrogen atoms of
benzene are equivalent;"
(that's what Koerner actually
proved) "and (2) Each
hydrogen atom of benzene has two
sets of two others which are
symmetrically arranged with
respect to it;
that is, 1.2 is the same as
1.6, and 1.3 is the same as 1.5,
although 4 is unique with
respect to 1."
(Okay?
So there are two that are
symmetrically arranged.)
"Already several years ago
I had occasion to make
Kekulé
aware that his graphical
formula for benzene is not
adequate,
since here 1.2 and 1.6 must be
inequivalent,
while one could have various
views about whether positions 3
and 5 are equivalent or
not."
Why would one and two be
certainly -- two and six,
that is, be certainly
inequivalent,
but three and five might or
might not?
Yeah, Kate?
Student:  Because
between one and two is a double
bond and between one and six is
a single bond.
Prof: Both have a single
and a double.
But what about 1.3 and 1.5?
Are they 100% equivalent?
Student:
>.
Prof: Ah ha!
because one is single-double
and the other is double-single,
going the other way.
So that might or might not be
equivalent, Ladenburg says.
"Both conditions could,
however, be fulfilled through
alternative formulas which,
so far as I know,
have not been proposed
before."
So here are Ladenburg's
formulas.
And the one in the middle,
the triangular prism,
actually came to be called,
100 years later,
or a little,
seventy years later,
Ladenburg benzene,
right?
Because someone was able to
synthesize that.
It's also called prismane,
because it looks like a prism,
right?
And then there's this funny
structure on the right.
Okay, so this is 1872,
and we're going to --
there's van't Hoff,
who is an eighteen-year-old
student,
come to Bonn to see the great
Kekulé.
And he writes,
in 1876, at the age of 24,
a reply to Ladenburg.
"Proof that the prism
formula"
(of Ladenburg) "suffers
from the same problem as the
hexagon with fixed double bonds
removes the previously asserted
superiority from the
former" (from the prism)
"and makes the original
Kekulé
notation not only simpler,
but also the presentation with
which the facts conform
best."
Because Kekulé
had the idea that what these
lines really meant was how often
the bonds collide --
how often the atoms collide
with one another.
They collide more often,
he thought, when it's a double
bond than when it's a single
bond.
So he thought that in this
case, although you would draw
single,
double, single,
double, that the number of
collisions actually was the same
one way and the other.
So you'd draw both formulas to
be in between what we would call
now resonance formulas.
So anyhow, this young student,
twenty-four years old now,
says Ladenburg's off base in
saying the prism is better,
because it has the same problem
and you can't get out of it with
this vibration thing.
Okay, "The 1,2; 5,6;
and 3,4 derivatives are
completely similar,
although differing from 4,5;
2,3; 6,1."
So 1,2; 5,6;
and 3,4 are completely similar.
So here's 1,2; 3,6;
-- 1 5,6; and 3,4.
Right?
And you can see that just by
rotating by 120°
you go from one to the next.
So those he says "are
completely similar,
although differing from 4,5;
2,3; 6,1."
Do you see how they differ?
4,5; 2,3; 6,1.
Now are the red and the blue
different or not?
The reds, obviously you just
rotate and you get from one to
the next.
How about from a red to a blue?
Can you rotate to get from one
to the other,
from a red to a blue?
Say the one's in front?
What happens if you rotate to
put a red line on a blue line?
Student:  It's sitting
on a square face.
Prof: Sam?
Student:  It's sitting
on a square face instead of --
Prof: Ah,
then it's sitting on a square
face instead of triangular face.
It's not the same anymore.
Everybody see that?
Right?
This, as drawn,
it has a triangle on top.
If you turn it 180°
, so as to superimpose the blue
in front, on the red,
then you no longer have a
triangle on top.
It's not the same thing,
van't Hoff, twenty-four years
old, says.
What do you think Ladenburg
would say about that?
Well we'll see.
But van't Hoff goes on.
He says: "A 1,3 product is
different according to whether A
or B occupies position 1."
(In the right,
there's single double,
double single,
when you go from A to
B.***Okay?)
"Exactly the same thing
happens in Ladenburg's
formula."
(With the prism.)
"An adequate consideration
shows that I and II are
absolutely different."
So one.
And notice he puts dashed lines
in.
Why?
Why is one bond shown dashed?
Says so, right?
Because it's behind,
it's hidden.
So he's definitely showing this
in three dimensions.
And if it's in three
dimensions, then AB goes left to
right,
in one, and right to left in
the other,
and you can't superimpose them,
they're not the same thing;
according to van't Hoff.
Now what would Ladenburg say
about this?
He wouldn't take it lying down.
He wrote back and said,
"van't Hoff finds the two
formulas below absolutely
different."
How is what he wrote different
from what van't Hoff wrote?
How are Ladenburg's formulas
different from van't Hoff's?
Pardon me?
It's not what?
Student:  It isn't in 3D.
Prof: How do you know
whether it's in 3D or not?
Student:  Well,
then he'd use a dashed line.
Prof: Ah,
he doesn't use the dashed line.
Okay?
So he says they're absolute --
that van't Hoff finds them
absolutely different.
But he's just drawing
constitution,
what's linked to what.
Right?
"I cannot agree with him
in this.
Van't Hoff is dragging
something into the formulas
which I, together with most
chemists, expressly exclude.
I refer to the arrangement in
space."
(Right? So keep that out. Okay?)
"The formula takes account
of the composition,
molecular weight,
and mode of union of the
atoms."
So composition and what else?
What other C?
Student:
>.
Prof: Composition,
that's composition of molecular
weight he says;
and the "mode of
union," right?
Which is constitution.
It doesn't talk about
arrangement in space.
Right?
"If van't Hoff's view of
space really will not tolerate
the two formulas above to be
identical,
then I invite him,
for his own special purposes,
to use a different benzene
formula,
which was proposed by me in the
year 1869,
when I compared the hexagon and
the prism for the first time,
together with the prism,
to which it is for me certainly
identical.
It is the so-called Cross of
David.
Even van't Hoff will have to
find that these two formulas are
absolutely identical."
Okay, now how could the prism
be identical to this?
There's the prism.
They certainly don't look
identical.
But watch this.
Let's twist it;
keep all the bonds,
but twist it.
Right?
So as long as you don't have
dashed lines for 3D,
they're the same;
one is just twisted.
Okay?
So Ladenburg is expressly
keeping this out.
Now this point of view survived
for quite awhile.
Here's some notes taken by a
former Yale colleague,
R.M. Fuoss,
in the 1920s,
when he was a student at
Harvard in Kohler's course.
His notes say:
"Benzene gives one
monosubstitution product and
three disubstituted.
Cyclohexatriene"
(if you had the ring with
double single,
double single) "apparently
requires four disubstitution
products.
should be different,
it was argued."
But then he shows another
example of an experiment that's
been done here,
with this molecule.
Now these hydrogens can be --
it turns out that those
hydrogens we'll call later
Î± hydrogens,
because they're the first,
next to a carbonyl group.
So here's a carbon-oxygen
double bond, and then a C that
has the H;
carbon-oxygen double bond,
a C that has the H.
Those are called Î±.
And it was known that it's
possible to easily substitute
Î± carbons with other
things;
more easily than other carbons
typically, other hydrogens.
So you'd expect to get two
possible structures.
You could do this Î±
one and get the R in that
position, or this one and get R
in that position.
So you'd get two products.
Right?
Those two.
"We can alkylate"
(that is, put the R group on)
"glutaconic acid in several
ways,
but we always get the same
product 1.
2 cannot be made,
no matter how we go.
Hence it is not surprising that
only one ortho disubstituted
product for benzene exists.
The double bonds shift until
the stable system is
reached."
Right? So you can't make one.
Or if you make it,
it immediately transforms to
the other one.
So there could be two,
but there aren't.
Okay? So this is what?
This is forty years later,
almost half a century later,
and he's still saying the same
thing.
Okay?
Now, is it really that?
Well you can calculate by
Spartan that the minimum energy
really is symmetrical with equal
bond distances,
but it vibrates.
It can vibrate like this --
right?
-- in and out,
and the frequency of that is
1276 wavenumbers.
You've taken spectra,
you've seen that kind of thing.
Although this particular one is
not active in the infrared.
You can't see it in IR.
It's called breathing.
>
Right?
Okay, but there's another way
it can vibrate,
like this: distort in that
direction, then back to
symmetrical, and in the other
direction.
See what that is?
That's distorting in the
Kekulé
direction, single double,
single double.
Right?
So that one is at 1367
wavenumbers;
the Kekulé distortion.
But it's around a single
minimum.
So at any given time the thing
is probably vibrating.
So it is single double,
single double.
But the lowest energy is all
the same intermediate distance.
Okay, now might you be able to
push on benzene and make it
favor the Kekulé
structure, with alternating
bond distances?
Well that's a challenge.
So a chemist named Jay Siegel
and his colleagues synthesized
this one,
which you'll notice has a
four-membered ring,
with funny bond angles,
attached to one side of the
benzene.
That means those angles are
going to be stretched and so on.
So they're going to distort and
make that bond different.
And indeed that bond,
1,6, is a little
different.
But on the other side…
if it made that one -- let's
say it's a little bit long;
make it single and the
neighbors double,
because of the way it's being
stretched --
then if that propagated around
the ring,
single double,
the ones on the left would be
different lengths.
But in fact they're the same.
Right?
So it doesn't happen here.
So that's the kind of thing
that people sometimes do to test
out the limits of these kinds of
theories.
Okay, so we've seen the
position determination.
And now more about tetrahedral
carbon.
And to get there we're going to
step back just a bit to look at
Louis Pasteur,
who was in a different line of
business at this time.
Now it's hard to prove that two
samples are identical because
there could always be some other
test in which they appear to be
different,
even though everything you've
done so far shows them the same.
But let's take carvone as an
example.
Here's a sample of carvone,
a bottle of carvone.
And if I crack it a little bit,
I can smell it.
It has a very nice smell.
Here, I'll pass it around here.
Don't spill it obviously.
Do you recognize the odor?
Actually I have another bottle
too.
Here let's start this one over
here.
I'll start it with Catherine.
So just smell that one.
Don't put your nose right down
in it.
But it's not that strong.
It's very pleasant actually.
Now, this stuff is called
carvone.
There's a reason it's called
How are you doing Rick,
with your grinding?
Can you smell anything on it?
Student:  Definitely can
smell it.
Prof: What does it smell
like?
Student:  It smells to
me like -- I'm not sure if I
know the exact name but it's a
little like sesame seeds --
Prof: A little like
sesame seeds.
But there's another -- pass it
to Shai next to you here,
let him smell.
Is it familiar?
How about anybody?
How about the bottle here
coming?
Do you notice it?
Is it a familiar scent?
Student:  Smells like
peppermint.
Prof: It's spearmint,
not peppermint.
But you're close.
Shai, how are you doing?
Does it smell like peppermint
to you?
Student:  I couldn't say
what kind mint it smells like.
Prof: A little bit like
mint.
Okay, how are doing Yoonjoo?
You're grinding up a different
stuff.
You're grinding dill seed,
in fact.
Does it smell?
Student:  Yes it does.
Prof: What does it smell
like?
Dill seed maybe, right?
But carvone comes from -- this
is a familiar scent.
I'm surprised you didn't get
it, Shai.
Did anybody else recognize?
Did you get it, Andrew?
No.
How about the bottle that's
coming along the back row there,
that little bottle?
Yeah, notice it?
Student:  Rye.
Prof: It's rye.
Rye bread has that.
It's caraway,
those seeds are caraway.
And caraway is -- carv
is the Latin root for it.
It's like caraway, right?
So carvone, this substance
we're passing around,
carvone, caraway.
Okay?
Now, so let's look at the --
suppose we took these two
bottles and you distilled them,
found the boiling point.
Both bottles have 230-231°.
Right?
The densities are exactly the
same.
The refractive indices for
those two bottles,
how much they bend light when
it goes through,
exactly the same.
The infrared spectra are
identical;
to the extent that any IR
spectra are identical.
You know from experiment that
if you put more in one sample
than in another they don't look
the same.
Right?
Did you notice that in lab?
If you ground up more stuff and
less stuff, the spectra don't
really look the same,
but then you can find there is
a peak to peak correspondence;
the intensities are never going
to be exactly the same.
But to the extent IR spectra
can be the same,
these are the same.
If you take their NMR spectra
they're the same.
So they must be the same.
Or is there any property in
which they differ?
Any property that those two
bottles differ in?
Students:  Smell.
Prof: The smell is
different.
Now, those bottles -- they're
in dark bottles,
to protect them from light.
But if I poured them out --
they should be colorless liquids
but I bet anything they're brown
-- right?
-- because they've sat around
and a little bit is oxidized.
So it's very difficult with
scent, because little bits of
other things can make them smell
a little different.
Right?
You don't need much stuff for
scent of the proper thing.
So it's hard to be confident
that this difference,
that one of them is rye bread,
caraway, and the other is
spearmint;
it's hard to be sure that
that's a difference.
But it turns out there's
another property you can measure
too.
And Karo syrup has that
property.
And I'm going to show it to you.
It's the ability to rotate
polarized light.
Now -- oh, did I bring?
-- oh I forgot to bring my
Polaroids.
So what I'm going to do is ask
a TA to go back to my office,
and on the table in my office
there's a brown package about
that big that has two sheets of
Polaroid in it.
There's the key.
Yeah, it's not here.
Sorry.
Let me think a second,
what we can go on to.
I'll tell you the measure of
this, which is you have light
that's polarized.
Have you all dealt with
polarized light?
You probably have polarized
sunglasses and you can turn it
and see different light
reflecting off things.
Have you done that?
Okay, and that's why you have
polarized sunglasses,
because light that reflects
doesn't go through the
particular direction that's in
the sunglasses.
So you get rid of reflected
light.
Okay, so but what you measure
is -- when light goes through a
polarized filter,
it's as if it were -- you were
shaking a rope and it was going
through a picket fence.
It can vibrate one way but it
can't vibrate the other way.
What vibrates in light?
What is vibrating?
What's light?
We went through this before.
Student:
Electromagnetic --
Prof: Electromagnetic
radiation.
What's vibrating?
Prof: The electric field.
And it's set up so one of
these, if you have a Polaroid
filter, gets absorbed,
and the other one comes
through.
Okay, so light that comes
through is vibrating this way.
And if you put another one,
that's crossed with it,
like this, what do you get --
what do you see?
Student:  Nothing.
Prof: Nothing,
because the first one stops one
and the second one stops the
other one.
If you turn it like this,
then it goes on through.
Okay?
But suppose that you put
something in the middle that
rotated the plane of
polarization.
So the light's vibrating like
this.
Suppose it's going like this.
Right?
Suppose by the time it gets to
the second filter it's like
this.
Right?
Now you have the second one
like this.
What do you see?
Light comes right on through,
because that's the way it's
vibrating now;
if you rotated the plane of
polarization.
Okay?
That's what
"rotation"
means.
Okay, now you measure this
property of a substance and call
it specific rotation;
which is how many degrees it
rotates.
And you have to say what light
rotates, so that the units of
Î± are degrees -- how many
degrees it changes,
per gram per milliliter.
If you put more stuff in,
then you get a bigger effect.
Right?
So it depends on the
concentration.
So how many degrees per mole,
you might say.
Okay?
But then it's per decimeter,
because the longer path you go,
if it's rotating,
the further you go,
the further it twists.
So the old style cells were --
oh, no, that's not it.
Nice try.
This is really embarrassing.
It's an envelope.
Teaching Assistant:
Oh it's an envelope.
Oh okay.
Prof: Did you see it?
Teaching Assistant:
I can take another look.
Prof: Okay,
good >
Okay, let me show you the other
things I'm going to show you.
Okay here -- actually here's --
we'll do a trick.
Here are models of carvone.
Okay?
Now I'm going to give them to
you guys, and I want you to
compare and see if they're the
same.
Stand up and let people see
what -- so decide how you --
start maybe at the top,
with the methyl group.
Each of you -- turn -- both of
you turn and face the thing,
so they can see.
Now hold -- start with the
methyl group at the top.
It starts with the methyl group.
Now Russell,
you describe it and then check
and see whether -- Eric,
you check and see whether your
model is the same as Russell's.
Okay?
While you're doing that,
I'll go help find the thing.
So tell me when I get back.
<<Professor McBride
leaves the class briefly>>
Prof: Okay what's the
answer?
Are they the same?
Student:  One of them's
pointing down.
I can't see it on the other
one.
Prof: So is that real,
do you think?
Is that just a peculiarity of
the models, or does that relate
to molecules?
Student:  I think it
should relate to the smell of
the thing.
Prof: Okay.
Well anyhow -- if I can catch
my breath -- these are Polaroid
sheets.
So here you see me,
and here you don't.
Students:  Ohhh.
Prof: Okay?
Now, let's see a case of
rotation.
So here you see crystals and
I'll put this -- I'll get light
coming through.
And there's the Polaroid
filter, and here's another
Polaroid filter.
Right? So I turn it 90°.
And now let me put the crystals
in there.
Now, so there,
most of it's coming through.
But now watch.
What do you notice?
Student:
>.
Prof: What's happening?
Student:
>.
Prof: What's surprising
about this?
Obviously they're rotating the
plane of polarization -- right?
-- so that I have to set a
different angle in order to stop
the light.
But what's special about this
set of crystals?
<<Students speak over one
another>>
Prof: Some are
right-handed and some are
left-handed.
Right?
That's sodium chlorate.
That's the stuff that
Gay-Lussac used.
Right?
So this property was
discovered, of crystals,
early in the century.
Now how about liquids?
Will liquids do it?
Well here's glass.
Glass doesn't do anything
special, it's just like the air
around it.
But let me pour water in here,
and see if water does the
trick.
Nothing special, right?
So let's try Karo syrup.
It's not quite January,
but it takes a little while.
It's a little bit yellow.
It sat around awhile.
What's happening?
Well there's an underlying
yellow that biases this.
But we can get different colors.
So different colors in the
spectrum are being blocked out.
How can that be,
for different angles different
colors?
So the Karo syrup is rotating
the polarization,
but it's rotating different
colors different amounts.
Right?
So we block off different
colors at different angles.
Okay, so if we're going to make
a measurement of the angle,
how much it rotates,
we're going to have to say what
color we're talking about.
And that's what the D is.
The D is the color.
There's a so-called D line of
sodium, a yellow color.
The yellow street lights are
that color.
Right?
So that's the color that was
used, because it was easy to
generate in the old times.
And twenty is how many degrees;
because it's different for
different temperatures.
Okay, so you can measure the
specific rotation of a sample.
And if it's in a solvent,
you have to say what solvent it
is, because it can vary with
solvent.
So anyhow, back to our
comparison.
These odors were the same,
but we might not believe it.
But if we measure the specific
rotation, it's equal and
opposite.
One is +62°
and the other is -62°.
So these things somehow are
mirror images of one another.
Now here is what you've already
seen.
You can write the structure of
carvone, either longhand or
shorthand.
And there are the two models.
And you correctly identified a
difference between them,
that one has a hydrogen
pointing backwards and the other
coming out toward you.
And is this difference real?
Of course there were
differences in the sausage
formulas too,
but those weren't real;
remember, those two compounds
turned out to be the same
compound.
The question is,
is this difference real?
Are there two carvones,
but with different impurities
in them, so they smell
different, or is there just one?
Oh pardon me,
vice-versa from what I said
there.
Okay, so tartaric acid turns
out to be the same thing.
Remember, Berzelius coined the
name isomer to talk about
tartaric acid and racemic acid,
which both came as byproducts
of the wine industry and had
very,
very different melting points.
So obviously they're quite
different from one another.
And one of them turns out to
rotate light;
if you make an experiment like
this.
It rotates light to the right,
by 13° per gram,
per milliliter,
per decimeter.
Okay.
But if you heat it,
you get another compound called
pyrotartaric acid,
or sometimes meso-tartaric
acid.
Meso doesn't mean anything,
except "between".
Do you know any cases where
meso means between?
Mesopotamia means between the
Tigris and the Euphrates River,
right?
So it just means in between.
So there was another one in
between tartaric and racemic
acid.
It wasn't between in melting
point;
it had 140°
as its melting point.
And it didn't rotate light
either.
So there were these three
different forms of tartaric
acid, but all were found to have
the same constitutional formula;
the same things linked to the
carbons.
So here's a problem with the
model, in terms of isomer
numbers.
Okay?
Sometimes too many isomers are
predicted, like Paternó's
dibromoethane.
He had different phases of
rotation;
said those were different.
In fact, they weren't
different, it was just
experimental errors of someone
who thought they were different.
So sometimes the model predicts
too many isomers.
But often, or sometimes at
least, it predicts too few;
as in the case of maleic and
fumaric acid where you have a
double bond.
There are two different
substances with different
melting points and properties.
With lactic acid -- remember
that Scheele had found lactic
acid from milk,
but Liebig had found it from
meat --
and they were the same,
it was found out about this
time by a guy named Wislicenus.
They had the same constitution,
but one rotated to the right
and the other rotated to the
left.
There was tartaric and racemic
acid;
which was even more complicated
because there was also
meso-tartaric and also what came
to be called l-tartaric
acid.
And that was the discovery of
Pasteur.
So in 1848, which was another
revolutionary time in France,
Pasteur was twenty-six years
old and was becoming an
interdisciplinary scientist:
chemistry,
physics, crystallography,
all he was studying.
And he wrote a paper called
"On the relations that can
exist among crystalline
form," (so crystallography)
"chemical
composition,"
(chemistry) "
and the direction of rotatory
polarization."
That is this stuff we're
talking about,
which is physics.
Now remember we talked about
Mitscherlich and the ability to
measure angles on crystals and
tell -- distinguish crystals by
their angles.
So these are pictures that
Pasteur was using to draw his
salts of tartaric acid.
In particular sodium -- it's a
diacid, and so you can have
different cations;
sodium ammonium tartrate is
this one.
And there's his picture that he
drew of it.
And he said -- mostly you see
the faces that are shown in that
picture, but sometimes you can
see other little faces.
Right?
And you notice that the
crystals have symmetry.
They have a horizontal plane of
symmetry and also a vertical
plane of symmetry.
Right?
So if you can see one of those
edges,
you should see the others that
are related by symmetry this
direction,
symmetry this direction,
and also symmetry this
direction.
So you should see all eight,
in the tartrate.
But always only four of them
are observed,
in sodium ammonium tartrate;
not all eight.
Mitscherlich had studied this
stuff, and he was sort of the
father of measuring angles like
this.
But when Pasteur was trying to
learn the technique and repeat
it,
he noticed that you don't very
often get these edges all
together,
these little tiny ones.
It usually looks like the
original picture did.
But when those sharp edges are
truncated by little additional
faces, you only see four,
you don't see all eight.
So Mitscherlich had reported
that the -- now how…?
-- That was tartrate, right?
Now they had the idea that
racemate,
which remember didn't rotate
light --
Pasteur's idea was that
molecules were twisted in a
right-hand or a left-handed
helix,
and therefore they had this
effect on light,
to make it twist.
Right?
But one's that aren't twisted,
like racemic acid --
Where the molecules aren't
twisted,
then, at least in those,
you should see all eight,
because you will have mirror
images.
Okay?
So he thought untwisted
molecules would be what's called
"holohedral";
that is, have all their faces.
So he studied the sodium
ammonium racemate and was quite
surprised to find that sometimes
he saw the red ones,
sometimes he saw the green
ones, but never on the same
crystal.
Some crystals were right,
red, and some were left,
green.
So he separated those crystals,
the right ones from the left
ones.
He wrote: "I carefully
separated the right from the
left crystals and observing
their dissolution separately,
with Monsieur Biot's
polarization apparatus"
(the thing that measures the
rotation) "I saw with
surprise and delight that the
right crystals deviated the
plane of polarization to the
right and the left to the
left."
So why did racemic acid not
rotate light?
Student:
>
Prof: Because it was a
50:50 mixture of things that
would rotate it one way --
it's not that it was untwisted
-- it was that some of them
would rotate it one way and some
would rotate it the other,
and they'd cancel out.
Okay.
Oops I improved this and forgot
to take that one out;
sorry.
Okay, so now he knows what's
going on,
that racemic acid is actually a
50:50 mixture of right-handed,
dextro-tartaric acid,
d, that has a plus
rotation,
and left-handed tartaric acid,
l,
levo, which has a minus
rotation, but the same melting
point,
the same rotation,
but opposite in direction.
So those are mirror images of
one another.
And the racemic acid is a 50:50
mixture.
Now this was 1848.
So that's a long time from
where we've gotten to.
Right?
That was ten years before the
idea of bonds.
Okay?
So that was
"resolution",
the separation of a mixture
into the two components.
Right?
But what is meso-tartaric acid?
Why doesn't it rotate?
So now we go forward,
twenty-four years,
to Bonn, and there's van't Hoff
studying with Kekulé,
at the age of twenty.
So that's a quarter of a
century.
That's a long time, right?
It's longer than you've lived.
So here's van't Hoff.
He had some opinion of himself.
He won the first Nobel Prize --
I mean, he had a high opinion
that was completely justified --
in 1901, the first Nobel Prize
in Chemistry.
And he didn't get it for this,
which he should've gotten it
for.
He got for inventing physical
chemistry.
The most admired trait he had
was imagination.
So he liked poets and artists.
In fact, his hero was Lord
Byron.
Look at that.
Okay?
And in 1874,
as we said, he was a student.
And he wrote this,
a pamphlet, in Dutch,
which was then translated into
German and called "The
Arrangement of Atoms in
Space," and was published
in 1877.
It was fifty-three pages long
and heavily illustrated.
And look at the website for
this.
One of the Wikis I've assigned
is that website.
And also this website about
criticism of van't Hoff by a guy
named Kolbe.
So here's Hermann Kolbe.
He was twice,
more than twice van't Hoff's
age, and a pillar of traditional
chemistry.
He wrote, in a review of this
book: "It is completely
impossible to criticize this
booklet in any detail because
the fancy trifles in it are
totally devoid of any factual
reality and are completely
incomprehensible to any
clear-minded researcher.
The brochure begins with the
words: 'The modern chemical
theory has two weak points.
It says nothing either about
the relative position or the
motion of the atoms within the
molecules.'"
This is absurd,
right?
But he was wrong.
Right?
Now am I like Kekulé?
Because I'm more than twice as
old as you are.
Right?
So those are three websites you
should read about this.
But, in fact,
it's not true that van't Hoff
was devoid of any factual
reality,
because we've already seen some
of his evidence,
and we'll see more next time.